let's talk about the six exercises that
can help get rid of those love handles
the medical term for love handles is a
muffin top but there's actually nothing
to love
about love handles for some reason
people
don't like their love handles and they
want to get rid of them so i'm going to
show you how so what's happening is that
you're getting fat accumulation in your
liver it's then filling up and then
spilling off into
around your organs and in your organs in
your midsection that's called visceral
fat and on top of that you're also
getting additional subcutaneous fat
which is just beneath the surface so
love handles are basically a spill off
of fat because there's not too many
places left so your body's just dumping
it on the sides of your waste now
there's one primary cause and there's
two secondary causes the primary cause
is basically you're eating too much
sugar refined carbs glucose which is
then raising insulin okay
in the presence of insulin you can't
burn fat and what you're doing is you're
storing fat and you're accumulating fat
so that's cause number one
but if you experience stress
that hormone cortisol will then activate
more insulin
because there's going to be a release of
glucose during stress your body runs on
glucose so stress produces glucose it's
called gluconeogenesis
because your body is stuck in this
stress mode or survival mode and the
quick energy is glucose so it'll turn
fat and protein into glucose and so
stress increases glucose thereby
increasing insulin then you have a lack
of sleep which can activate more
cortisol
which then activates more insulin this
is why
if your sleep is not that great you're
going to be craving carbs you'll be
hungry usually for carbs so we have a
high carb diet
we have stress
and then we have lack of sleep and so
the solution is to get on a low carb
diet reduce your stress and improve your
sleep but that's not all you're going to
have to add some exercise to really
speed up the process so these are some
intense exercises to focus in on your
core which connects the lower part of
your body to the upper part of your body
okay the first exercise we're going to
talk about are side planks okay now
there's
several modifications that you can do
for side planks that can make things
more or less challenging but this is
what you're going to do you're going to
start by laying on your side
and you're going to prop yourself up
with one arm your elbow should be in
alignment with your shoulder
and your forearm should be flat against
the ground
at a right angle to your body so you'll
stack your legs one on top of the other
so your body forms a straight line from
head to hip
now with your knee still touching the
ground raise your hips
squeeze your glutes the butt muscle and
then hold the move for about 30 seconds
now while doing this exercise focus on
keeping your abs tight to support your
body and then just switch sizes and then
repeat but this is a great exercise to
really
target that core that midsection and you
can add other exercises to this and do
this on a regular basis i would
recommend doing it every other day to
start out with all right number two
bicycle crunches now can be tempting to
rush through this exercise but the key
is to do it slowly and control your
movements so every muscle in your love
handle area can be affected so the first
thing you do is you're going to lie on
your back with your hands behind your
head and your knees bent
you'll lift up your shoulders and head
off the ground as you engage your abs at
the same time you're going to lift the
feet off the ground keeping your knees
bent so that your shins are parallel to
the ground then you're going to slowly
twist your body so your left elbow moves
towards your right knee
now as you twist your body extend your
left leg straight out in front of you
now slowly twist in the other direction
bringing your left leg back to the bent
position with your right elbow moving
towards your left knee as you twist the
body extend your right leg out in front
of you so you want to do between 15 and
30 repetitions but do what you can
because this is a very difficult
exercise for some people starting out so
just go slowly because you're going to
be sore the next day all right number
three russian twists this is another
seated exercise which is awesome for
getting rid of those love handles and
you can even modify this
by adding weight as you get good at it
but if you're new to this exercise do
not use extra weights so start in a
seated position on the floor with your
butt on the ground your knees bent and
your feet flat on the floor tighten your
abdomen lean your torso back so that
you're about to do a 45 degree angle to
the floor if you're not using a weight
clasp your hands together if you are
using weight hold your hands just above
your abdomen still with your knees bent
lift your feet off the ground so that
you're balancing on your butt for
additional support you can actually
cross your ankles now twist your torso
to the right
bring your clasp hands or your weight to
the right side of your body now twisting
to the left touching your weight or your
hands to the left side of your body
repeat this for about 30 seconds to one
minute
now of course this is another killer
exercise so again go at your own pace
the next exercise we're going to talk
about is the mountain climber boy this
one can really raise your pulse rate
your metabolism and strengthen your
abdominal muscles in a major way you can
start out going slow but then you could
speed things up as you get stronger so
to get in a plank position you're going
to lie flat on the floor face down place
your hands underneath your shoulders
curl your toes so that they're pressing
into the floor
and push up lift your right foot off the
ground and pull your right knee towards
your left elbow keeping your abs tight
hold the move briefly and then return
your foot to the original position now
repeat it on the other side so you want
to do this about 30 seconds to one
minute again every other day
all right number five wood choppers this
is another great exercise to get rid of
those love handles with this one you're
going to need a little ball a medicine
ball which actually has weight so stand
with your feet shoulder width apart
and raise both arms above your head on
the left hand side
bring your arms down towards the floor
on the right hand side of your body as
you perform a squat while you're
twisting your midsection in hips
perform this several times and then
repeat the other side so i would
recommend doing it maybe three to four
times and then reverse this to the other
side but with this exercise you really
want to focus on your form
and use the weight that you can easily
do this with so maybe you want to start
out with a
five pound
ball and then gradually go up to a seven
pound or even a ten pound ball but this
is an awesome exercise to get your core
in really good shape now the last
exercise i'm going to talk about
involves the bulgarian bag and you're
going to be swinging this bag over your
head now this is more for advanced
exercise i'm doing this exercise right
now and you talk about an intense
workout boy you can get your pulse right
up and you can get some serious
improvement with your midsection not to
mention your shoulders
now it's a bit more complex and it's
very difficult to explain so you're
going to have to kind of watch this
video and go slow and mimic the motion
until you get the rhythm but you're
basically involving a bag where you're
putting either rocks or sand in it at a
certain weight that you're comfortable
with i think the weight that i'm using
right now is about 20 pounds but i'm
telling you it's 20 pounds is pretty
intense so the first thing you're going
to do is you're going to grip
these two
ends of the bag and so one thing about
this exercise is that it takes a lot of
grip strength to hold this because
you're whipping this bag over your head
in a certain motion so you're going to
find that your forearms are going to be
very strong but if you don't have good
forearm strength the whole bag could
slip out very easily so the key is to
start at the right weight
so this exercise is kind of a swinging
uh back and forth and using your body to
counterbalance because as you're
swinging to the left you're shifting all
your weight to the opposite side and so
it's going to activate your obliques
your abdomen muscles and a lot of other
muscles as well so start with swinging
the bag side to side just to get used to
it and then make sure your heels are
planted downward as well and then as you
get comfortable you're going to actually
swing the bag
around your shoulders don't go too high
don't actually try to swing the bag
straight up and vertical but you're
going to be kind of swinging it over
your shoulders and twisting
as you go to the other side so it's a
torso rotation as you're shifting to
counter balance the weight of this bag
and as you bring the bag over your head
you're going to be twisting the bag in a
certain way so it can go around your
head this is an awesome exercise for
building your shoulders so i've worked
up where i can do 20
times one side and i'll go 20 times the
opposite side you really have to
remember to breathe because at first
you're going to be holding your breath
but you want to get in this rhythm this
cyclic motion shifting from the left
side of your body to the right side of
your body like a circle but this is an
awesome exercise to not just work on
your love handles but it's to get your
shoulders in shape as well all right so
there we have it the combination
of both changing your diet
and these powerful exercises now you
have to make sure
that you get on a healthy ketogenic diet
do intermittent fasting
and then you want to do these exercises
in the fasting period of time so you can
add compounding or enhancement of the
results now if you have not seen my
videos
on how to do keto and intermittent
fasting in a very simple way
i put them right here check it out